in this video we will be showcasing all
the different forms of rodan
that have appeared in the big screen
since 1956 onwards
till the most recent monsterverse titans
rodan as well as a bit upon
the upcoming singular point rodan which
will be seen in 2021
rodan has always been a fan favorite
since it appeared alongside godzilla in
1964
and his flying kaiju is made to look as
a giant pterosaur
which is not to be confused with a
dinosaur as they are both distinct
classes of ancient reptiles
in 2014 ign ranked rodan as number six
on their
top 10 japanese movie monsters while
complex
listed the character as number 15 on its
top 15
most badass kaiju monsters of all time
list
so let's see all these different roland
designs and forms starting with
number one titanos rodan the first one
on the list
that we will be showcasing is the
monsterverse fire demon
or scientifically dubbed as titanos
rodan in this movie it was
a hibernating titan that had been
sleeping for a very long time
under a dormant volcano in isla de mara
in mexico
in this incarnation it was a destructive
force of nature
that had the biggest wingspan of any
road until date it could sweep away
buildings if it flew low enough
and it was composed of lava inside his
body this form of rodan was
fiery looking and looked like a
pterosaur but with more
raptor-like beak a rodan here was 154
feet tall
and with a wingspan of 871 feet across
it possessed a texture similar to molten
rock with bumps and ridges along its
body
his wings were like a bat and his legs
had
hooked claws number two rodan 1956
the original roland came out in 1956
with a movie of the same name
this design is the only portrayal of
rodan to be mahogany in colour
this rodan design appears to have no
pupils
in the eyes however in a few sculpted
rammers
and makuts it had been shown to bear
pupils
this original design is also known as
shodai rado
which means first generation it featured
a
large but slim body enormous wings and a
large jagged head
this rodan's face was different from any
of the later suits as it had a menacing
angry expression on its face also its
beak was broader
more jagged and actually bare teeth
inside its mouth
on top of its head the suit had jagged
horns this rodent was 164 feet tall
and had a 394 feet wingspan
number three rodan from 1964 to 65.
this form of rodan made its first debut
appearance in godzilla's movies
in 1964 in the film ghidorah the
three-headed master
the sun dai kaiju raido form looks very
similar to his predecessor shoulda rado
but with significant differences
alterations from rhodan's previous
traits include more rounded wings with
show claws
a longer neck a smaller and thinner beak
and large expressive eyes in contrast to
the pitch-black eyes of should i rado
this form is of the same size and also
called as dyson sorredo
in an invasion of astral monster it was
the rodan form
used in two movies which are 1964 and
1965
and also in both of these movies it
appeared both as a rival and an ally of
godzilla
rodan 1968 the source shingeki rado is
the rodan design used in 1968
in the movie destroy all monsters the
social gekkiredo's name comes from the
film's japanese title
specifically so shingeki meaning attack
of the marching monsters
and naredo which is rodin's japanese
name a radon though similar in
appearance to its predecessors
should i radio and sunday kaiju rado
but this design the social geeky raider
form
has slightly longer horns the wings
appear to be longer and more
tyrannodont-like
and the beak is longer and pointed
downwards the size of this form is also
the same as the others
and in this one the face of this
particular rodan also appears to have a
droopy like
look into it which makes it look less
menacing and more goofy
rodan 1993 appearing in the 1993 movie
godzilla versus maker godzilla
in this form like the show of rodan it
resembles a gigantic pterosaur that
stands upright on two legs
however while technically 20 meters
taller than the shower incarnations
the heisei rhoda is considerably smaller
than the godzilla
he appeared alongside with rodin's wings
also appear somewhat larger in
proportion to the rest of his body
his swings have visible blood vessels
running through them
rodan possesses three spikes on the back
of his head instead of two
and to date it is the only incarnation
of the character
with this straight in addition he also
has a row of pointed spikes running down
the length of its back
as well as a pointed tail and rodan's
skin here
is initially brown in color fire rodan
seen in the same movie only in the later
scenes this
fire rodan was the main inspiration for
monster vs titanos rodan
the fire demon it was a more powerful
form of the same
normal roland and godzilla versus
mechagodzilla 1993
it came to be after godzilla sent the
normal rodent down to the dumbs
with two point blank atomic breath
attacks which so happens to be absorbed
by rodan's cells
and therefore transforming him into a
fire form which is stronger and develops
the ability to emit a purple colored
radioactive heat beam
from its mouth called the uranium heat
beam this rodin
as well as this normal form is 230 feet
tall
with a 394 feet wingspan and it is in
this form that it sacrifices itself to
save godzilla from death
number seven final wars rodan also known
as millennium rodan it is seen as a
giant tyrannodont kaiju who
appeared in the 2004 godzilla film
godzilla final walls
as a mind control pawn of the zillion
aliens and the millennium rodent is made
to closely resemble the 1956 original
design
with large wings spiky armored plates on
its chest
a long neck two horns on the back of its
head
unique aspects of this rodance design
include its orange colored skin
and especially long neck and legs upward
slanted horns and green eyes this
rhodan's body is considerably slimmer
and his armored chest plating is
yellow in color and extends down to his
legs rodan has pronounced fingers on
these wings in this design
and this design is extremely tall at 328
feet with a wingspan of 656 feet
across number eight singular point rodan
this form of roland will appear in the
upcoming movie godzilla's singular point
this incarnation of rodan retains the
character's co-design traits as being a
giant pterosaur with two
crests on its head and spikes on its
chest however
this rodan much more closely resembles a
real pteranodon in terms of his bodily
proportions
although seen in only the official
trailer this rodan is shaking it up with
controversies ahead firstly for his red
trail gas that appears behind it when it
flew past the city
secondly when it is seen in a big flock
which means it might actually be a
species
a whole species that still and lastly
when it appears
in a wholly different form with some
reddit users terming it as
the fire rodan form however this rodent
size is unknown
but it's hardly to be more than the size
of a house
and with this we come to the end of this
list of the nine forms and designs of
rodan
we hope you liked it and we will be
doing more videos like these for the
other kaiju like mothra and all
so do hit that like and subscribe button
to support us
and also do share it with your kaiju
friends but most of all do not forget to
smash that notification bell for regular
updates
on new and upcoming videos
you